I see.
Great. You're listening to radio,
the podcast from New York public radio and public radio [inaudible]. You
see
n n p. R. Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich Jad's,
not exactly sure where Jad is. I know he's at a meeting that I should be at too,
so not being exactly America's number one meeting person I got out of it so that
I could be here with you for which I thank you very, very much. So, uh,
this podcast,
today's podcast is one of our in between season occasionals where we share with
you our regular listeners an idea, a compelling conversation,
a thought in this case,
what you're about to hear is a big thought for me anyway,
I put it together for the graduating class at cal tech.
I was invited to be the commencement speaker there this past June and I wanted
to make a case for talking about science to folks who may not be all that well
versed or even all that interested in science. He things,
because talking about this stuff I argued has very powerful consequences.
So
thank you. I can't crush on. Thank you.
I was the only Shammo and thank you Judy Campbell and thank you congressman.
Shifting.
Thank you mayor Bagger and especially thank you to all 205 members of the cal
tech class of 2008 plus the extra 14. We're getting pretty close with aloud,
just sitting here, a congratulations to all of you. It's a great,
great honor to be here. Normally if you're a science reporter at NPR, at ABC,
you a trip to cal tech means that you call ahead and you asked for a few
precious moments with a world class intellectual, whatever,
and you're ushered in and you furiously take notes all the time thinking,
do I have any idea what this man is saying as woman,
I'm sure you know the feeling. And um,
when I got my invitation asking me to give you guys a lecture, I thought,
come on. I'm like, what can I tell you? But I thought of something. So,
and it's something that's going to happen to you.
You sitting here with the black hats, uh,
in the next hour or two there you'll be in your cap and gowns surrounded by your
family. And by friends and by friends of friends and somebody, you know,
maybe an uncle or a buddy, somebody there's going to turn to you and say,
so like what were you doing at cal tech? I mean, what, what were you working on?
Not that they really want to know, you know, but after all,
you've been here for four years, so you know, or even, you know,
different number. If you're a Grad student,
you must've been doing something here. So it's only polite to ask.
And I know that a lot of you have scientifically literate dads and moms and some
brothers and some sisters. Not all of them of course, but some. And uh,
let's just assume that one of these people, if they had to make it a relative,
let's say that he will make it. He, he's not a scientist, he's not an engineer.
And the last time he had a thought,
a complex thought about biology or math was back in 11th grade when he got the c
minus in both subjects and about never ever to think about biology or math ever
again.
But because this is your day and because this person loves you or because he
can't really think of anything to say after, Hey, uh,
he asks about your work and to make it still more interesting.
Let's assume that if you explain to this person what you've been working on,
you might have to use certain words like protein or cork or differential or
maybe hypothenuse and, and, and if you do, they're going to listen to you very,
very politely. But upstairs,
those words are going to be not a whole lot to them, you know,
because science is not their thing.
They can lip sync every word to instincts by, by, by, but you know,
high pop news is hard. So here's my question. When you are asked,
what are you working on? Should you think?
There's no way I can talk about my science with this guy because I don't have
the talent. I don't have the words, I don't have the patience to do it.
It's too hard. And anyway, what's the point? Which is, by the way,
not an unusual position, no less than Isaac Newton. And I mean Sir Isaac Newton,
that one when asked, why did you make your Principia Mathematica,
your here's chicken book about gravity and laws of motion,
so impossibly hard to read. He said, well,
I considered writing a popular version that people might understand,
but and I am quoting Newton here to avoid being baited by little sweaters in
mathematics. That was his phrase, little Smathers.
He intentionally wrote a book in dense scholarly Latin with lots of math so that
only scholars could follow. In other words,
Isaac Newton didn't care to be understood by average folks,
but here's the argument I want to make to you guys this morning and you're not
going to hear this advice often.
I suggest you ain't never hear it again when asked about your work,
do not do what Isaac Newton did. No, no, no.
When a cousin or an uncle or a buddy comes up and asks you,
so what are you working on? Even if it's hard to explain,
even if you know they don't really want to hear it, not really.
I urge you to give it a try because talking about science,
telling stories to regular folks is not a trivial thing.
Scientists need to tell stories to non scientists because science stories and
you know this have to compete with other stories about how the universe works
and how the universe came to be and some of those other stories, Bible stories,
movies, stories, myths can be very beautiful and very compelling.
But you protect science and scientists. This is not a gentle competition,
so you've got to get in there and tell yours your version of how things are and
why things came to be.
We all know about creation as science movements in America,
but what you may not know is that movements are spreading all over the world.
In Turkey there's a group led by a man named [inaudible].
He's a Muslim creationist and his group produced a picture packed 768 page
quote, biology unquote textbook that's priced very, very cheaply.
So schools can have it for next to nothing and that textbook is now used all
over Turkey.
It's written in clear and simple language using fabulous pictures and the
pictures are designed to prove that fossils show no evidence of evolution and
this group's books and their CD Roms and their grocery store magazines.
They have grocery store magazines.
Their websites are so widespread and so inexpensive and so provocative with
titles like the bloody ideology of Darwinism or the evolution deceit that in
Turkey's high schools, which are not religious schools,
they have a long secular tradition.
Their evolution and Darwin are disappearing from the curriculum in high schools
and that country. In 2006 when Turks were pulled and asked,
I want you to listen to this statement and tell us if it's true or false or you
don't know. Here's the statement. Human beings,
as we know them develop from an earlier species of animals in 2006 only 25% of
the Turkish public said yes to that. That's a very low number. In Japan,
78% say humans evolved from a Predator predecessor species in the u s it's,
it's 40% but that's above Turkey. In Turkey. There was a debate of course,
and they're still one sort of except Mr Octar sued people who opposed his views,
sued them for slander, managed to shut down their blogs in Turkey,
his followers attacked biology professors as a Maoists Maoists as Maoists for
teaching evolution,
which they called nothing but a deception imposed upon us by the dominators of
the world system.
High school teachers in Istanbul were fired because they taught evolution and
not creation science.
And while Mr Oxeye was recently arrested for his role in a sex ring operation,
so he may be taking a break.
Creation Science is now taught all over Turkey and while Turkey may seem and
ocean or more away, it is not.
There are always mister oak tars who aim their stories right at you,
right at the heart of a place like this,
at the values that cal tech has always honored from the beginning.
I know you spent long nights cramming and sweating under the weight of too many
assignments and too many tests and too many papers from too many professors who
didn't realize there were other professors that were making you do the same test
and the phone and so forth. But somewhere in that nightmare of work,
you may have noticed that your teachers were giving you more than tension
headaches. They were giving you values,
a deep respect for curiosity, for doubt.
Always doubt for openmindedness, for going wherever the data leads,
no matter how uncomfortable for honesty, for discipline,
and most of all the belief that anybody, no matter where they're from,
no matter what their language, no matter what their religion,
no matter what their politics, no matter what their age or their temperament.
I mean this place has seen monstrous egos and Bongo players and people who dress
in Viking hats.
But if you can learn how to sit down in a laboratory and think in an orderly
way,
and if you have the patience to stare and stare and stare and stare,
looking for a pattern in nature, you're welcome here.
It may be boring. It may be sometimes very exhausting,
but there's a freedom,
a freedom in this way of looking that is precious in the world.
And that freedom can be attacked or defended with stories,
stories matter after all what is a science experiment?
But you make up a story that may or may not be true and then you test that story
in the real world to see what happens. So for example,
let's say you're in Piazza,
it's 1590 and the guy named Galileo comes up to you and says hello there.
They actually probably wouldn't say it that way,
but you see I have a canon ball in my right hand. It's a very,
very heavy thing to be sure. But in my left hand, sir, I have a golf ball.
It wouldn't be golf balls before golf I my left hand, I have a musket ball,
which is lighter than the Canon Ball. Now, sir,
if I told you that these two balls if dropped from the same high place at the
same time, in spite of their five or 10 fold difference in weight,
that they would hit the ground simultaneously, the light one.
And the heavy one dropping landing at the exact same time.
Would you like to see me try whether Galileo actually did this or not?
If a guy named Galileo proposed this to you,
wouldn't you stick around just to see how it comes out? Galileo,
for my purposes is the great unknown. Newton, unlike Newton,
he had a flair for narrative, a storyteller's sense. Unlike Newton.
He wanted to tell people what was on his mind. Unlike Newton,
he thought that people could understand him.
That's why he got in so much trouble. In his famous book,
the dialogues about the sun being the center of the solar system.
He didn't write it in Latin.
He wrote it in Italian for a mass audience and the writing was gorgeous.
It was poetic. It was combative. It was funny.
It was a running conversation between three good friends who spend four days
together arguing and eating and boating through Venice in Gondolas.
The argument being,
is the earth the center of the solar system or might it be the sun?
And the text of that book has little pictures,
line drawings that he made and he put it in marginal headings to break up the
text so he wouldn't have a big sheet of writing.
And while there are numbers in his book,
he doesn't get to them until two thirds through the book.
And if you skip the numbers you don't miss that much.
So because Galileo's book was so easy to read and such a page Turner,
it's so threatened,
the established order that Galileo as you know was put under house arrest and it
wasn't just his science that was alarming.
I think it was the power of his storytelling.
That's what made him extra dangerous because stories have this power,
people like them, you know Wilson,
the great scientist and the great storyteller writes that science like the rest
of culture is based on the manufacturer of narrative. We all live by narrative.
He is know that half of it I work on radio and TV and I've learned that I can go
on Primetime TV and I have and do an hour on string theory and talk about
multiple dimensions and space time curvature. And supersymmetry.
This is very odd and very hard stuff for grandma,
for your brother and the cousin I was talking about before and yet a whole lot
of people, a few million people will sit there the whole time.
I mean ABC clocks, this kind of thing.
And they sit and they watch and apparently I have to assume they're pretty
fascinated, but the program ends and then you have like a bunch of ads,
like seven commercials and one network Id and three and a half to five minutes
pass. And the next program comes on the very same channel and it's about
extraterrestrials landing and anti gravity machines to examine the breasts of
innocent cocktail waitresses.
And the same people who are watching the previous hours sit there with the same
sense of awe and the same sense of fascination. And they say, wow.
And they kind of believe it too. People are not scrupulous about stories,
truths, fiction.
It's like this endless back and forth between Ross and Phoebe and the TV show
friends. If you know the show. We're also as a paleontologist,
he studies dinosaurs. Phoebe is his misuse French. He doesn't study anything,
but she knows everything. And in a typical episode,
Ross sits down and very carefully explains how opposable thumbs evolved slowly
over time. And Phoebe listens very respectfully and Ross finishes.
So he says,
you see how evolution explains opposable thumbs or says Phoebe,
maybe the overlords need them to steer their spacecrafts.
So people can slip very easily from reason to fantasy and they believe both and
they don't feel a need to be consistent.
They just want to feel like they're absorbed, like they're swept away.
And when you tell stories, boy, this hat is driving me nuts.
I'm going to just shit. You can't do it.
Only me. Uh, and I don't know what's wrong with my hair,
but man, I just forgive me here. When you tell stories to America,
really to anybody in the world,
you have to remember there are lots of Phoebe's stories with gripping visuals
and good punch lines and stories that make intuitive sense.
That makes sensual sense to your eyes and to your ears and to your touch.
They can convince they have power. You may not believe that two balls,
one heavy and one light jock from the same high place we'll drop together.
But if you see it with your own eyes that you remember,
and as science gets harder at the metaphor becomes more useful and even
necessary.
I mean more and more of what science teachers about the world is not intuitive
that way it makes no sensual sense.
This starts early in high school that if you slap your hand on a hard surface
like, like that,
the outer electrons on my hands and the electron on this wood here are repelling
each other. This is the electromagnetic forces. You know,
electronics just don't like being around other electrons.
So the reason my hand didn't go through the surface then is that two platoons of
electrons, mine and the tables on a line of scrimmage got in each other's face.
Okay?
That's harder though to add faces and motives and football analogies to
electrons. So there are some of you sitting here,
probably here who say you can't talk about nature that way it distorts what's
true.
What's true is what you see in equations in the math that points to these laws.
But I go back to my man Galileo,
who was maybe the first in western tradition anyway,
to honor mathematics as the primal force of knowledge,
the logic of the universe. He said in his book,
the SAR is written in the language of mathematics without which one is wandering
around in a dark labyrinth. But having honored math,
Galileo was very happy to create beautiful metaphors,
to invent marvelous characters, to draw pictures.
He knew how to light that labyrinth so the rest of us could see inside because
the more abstract and mathematical science gets,
the more we need to imagine something concrete.
As the physicist Alan Lightman has said,
we are blind people inventing what we don't see,
and yet 400 years later,
many scientists become a very weary of metaphors of adjectives,
of the active tents. It was observed that is much nicer for these people.
For some reason that I saw, and I can tell you from personal experience,
they do not like talking to reporters because they think whatever they say,
this journalist person is going to turn it into something stupid and cartoony
and wrong, and yeah, you're applauding. But, and maybe that's true,
but I was happy to learn that these people are just as nasty about each other.
My favorite example
is a pair of letters from Werner Heisenberg and Erwin Schrodinger.
Two of the 20th century is great physicist.
Schrodinger liked to think in pictures.
His most famous one being the image of a cat in a box who paradoxically is both
alive and dead at the same time. Don't ask.
The point is Schrodinger love pictures and Heisenberg, he loved numbers.
And when shorting a read Heisenberg's papers and they were so mathematical,
he wrote, I am repelled his word.
I am repelled by the methods of transcendental Algebra. That's so lack,
visualized, stability. And Heisenberg answered back, Oh yeah, by, I mean,
probably didn't say it that way. The more I reflect on Schrodinger's work,
the more disgusting I find it. And disgusting is a quote.
It's Heisenberg's word.
So there is a tension here among scientists between two kinds of truth,
math and narrative, but the job that we faced,
and I should come clean with you and tell you what's really on my mind here,
is to put more stories out there about nature that are true and complex,
not dumbed down, but still have the power to enthrall to excite,
to remind people there's a deep beauty, a many leveled beauty in the world.
And what scientists say is not their off hand opinion.
It's hard one information. It's carefully hewn from the world.
It's not the bunch of ideas from a tribe of privileged intellectuals who look
down on everybody even though they are indeed up here looking down on you.
But it's my sense that if more scientists wanted to,
they could learn how to tell their stories with words and pictures and metaphor
and people will hear and remember those stories and not be as willing to accept
the other folk stories. Or at least there'll be a tug of war.
And I think that the science stories too will surprisingly win.
I remember standing on the rim of the Grand Canyon looking down to that enormous
hole created by running water, endlessly running water,
felt fed by a distant Colorado rain. And I thought, you know,
how did this beautiful thing happen?
And in my head I heard a line written by Lauren Isley, a great,
great scientist and writer, a line I read in college,
which describes the magnificent violence hidden in a raindrop.
And when I look back at the canyon at the roaring river there,
that's what I saw.
Magnificent violence hidden in a torrent of old green drops.
Now we can't all be that good. And even when we try, we don't always win again.
I'm thinking of Ross again, poor Ross and the show friends,
he puts 200 fossils in front of Phoebe.
He brings him in a suitcase to show her how overtime fossils gradually change
and evolve into recognizable forms. And he said,
I'm going to lay them out for you, all for you to see.
And you're going to see this with your own eyes.
Cause these fossils are from all over the world. And Phoebe says, really?
You can actually see it. And Ross says, you bet from the u s China, Africa,
all over. And Phoebe says, well, you know, I didn't none of that.
Or Russell as well. There you go. And Phoebe says, Huh?
So now the real question is who put those fossils there and why?
So yes, science stories don't always win, but at the very least,
it should be a tug of war. And if you tell them right,
they have power to change minds. On my way here,
I read a story in Smithsonian magazine as a good example of what I'm talking
about. Imagine that you're sitting on your porch with a friend,
a non-science friend, and as you sit there,
a Robin and ordinary Robin wanders onto the lawn and you say to your friend,
you see that Robyn? Did you know that Robbins, in fact,
all birds are directly descended from dinosaurs.
And in a way that Robin is a small, feathery, modern dinosaur.
Huh? And if your friends are like my friends, she would say, well,
let me go away, but don't go away. Instead, you could tell them a story,
which is how I'm going to conclude. Eight years ago, Bob Harmon,
who works for the Museum of the Rockies,
was having lunch in a canyon somewhere in Montana,
and he looked up at a big rock face and he saw a bone sticking out of a wall
just a bit. The bone turned out to be part of a tyrannosaurus rex,
one of the best preserved examples of a TRX found anywhere.
And after three years of carefully, carefully, carefully chipping away,
they got a 2000 pound skeleton out of the wall and it was removed from the
canyon. And the dinosaur was named Bob in honor of Mr. Harmon.
And on the way out for various logistical reasons, they had to break a leg bone.
And some of the fragments were sent to laboratory scientists around the world,
including to a scientist in North Carolina named Mary Schweitzer.
So Mary Schweitzer gets a bone of a bone fragment in the mail and she opens it
up and she looks at it. And although Bob the dinosaur was 68 million years old,
almost immediately, she said, as soon as she look, this is not a Bob,
this dinosaur is a girl and she's a pregnant girl.
And what Mary knew is that when women get pregnant,
they use calcium from their bones to build the skeletons of their developing
fetuses. And if the mother's a bird mother,
well birds form a very distinct structure in their bones when they're pregnant
and they need calcium to build eggs, egg shells.
So Mary had studied birds and when she looked at the dinosaur bone fragments,
she saw just what pregnant birds have. But you know, just to be sure,
she looked up the most primitive birds, the moo and the ostrich.
And she called a bunch of ostrich beaters in North Carolina and she said,
anybody have a dead female? I need a, I need a leg bone here.
And a few months pass and the phone rings and it's a farmer saying,
y'all need that lady ostrich.
And Mary and her two assistants drove to this farm to collect a dead ostrich,
which was in the farmers' backhoe bucket. And drove it back to Raleigh.
And what do you know? The former ostrich had been a pregnant former Austrian,
and the next year Mary published a paper in science,
which shows the dinosaur bone right next to the ox of the ostrich bone showing
nearly identical features. And since then another t-rex,
this one in Argentina was found to have the same calcium structure.
So there's more evidence here that when you look deep inside dinosaurs and deep
inside birds, what you see is very, very similar,
which gives us yet another reason to think that the Robyn in your front yard is
an Itty bitty dinosaur.
And then Mary went on to do many more interesting things about dinosaurs.
But if you are non-science,
Fran can listen to that story and lean in a little and hear how scientists work
with bones and dead birds and buckets patiently looking for patterns.
You have just placed a sword in the hand of your friend.
So the next time somebody tells her that scientists are no idols who toss off
opinions, that scientists science is an elitist plot. She would think, well,
but I did hear this story and the scientific method gets a little more defense,
a little protection, but better than that,
the next time your friend sees a Robin, she'll see,
I hope more than a Robin. She'll glance it,
a little bird pecking for worms on the lawn and she'll travel 60 million years
back in time to a place which creation is say did not exist.
But now because of your story,
your friend has a pregnant tyrannosaurus in her head.
But the unfortunate name Bob,
which makes Robbins and Sparrows and chickadees and crows and all birds,
just a little more amazing and a little more delightful to look at,
which means you win. The creation is can't be delight.
You have smoked them with your story.
So Ladies and gentlemen of the class of 2008 mindful of the fact that this
place, this institution,
which is about to confer upon you a bachelor's of science degree and all your
others here and there who are getting your master's is in your doctorates.
Knowing as you much that places like this with their culture of intellectual
freedom and respect for truth and love of inquiry,
not to mention illegal bonfires on city streets and basketball teams that lose
207 games in a row, but not the women's team.
I heard that they're astonishing. Two game back to back winning streak. Yes,
yes. You know,
you know that when you receive your degree today,
you are part of and you are celebrating something very rare and very precious
and very fragile. In our world,
this place celebrates freedom and because you are now free men and women,
you have to protect what you've been given by helping others who haven't been
here and are never coming here to understand the value of what you do and what
your teachers do and what their predecessors have done,
which is why an hour or so from now when your brother or your aunt or your mom
asks you, so why don't you been up to while you've been here? Take a chance,
find the words, find the metaphor,
share the beauty and tell them what's on your mind. Tell them a story.
Thank you very, very much.
Thank you very much Robert,
for sharing your stories and your challenges with us.
I can't really imagine any more appropriate words for Caltech commencement.
I'd like you all to turn before in your program and joined the Cal Tech League
club.
So
that's what I told the Caltech Eas. If you have any beef or any thoughts,
any reaction, I'd love to hear what you think.
You can write us at our website and again,
we'd like you to hang onto the fall when we have a whole new season of radio
lab.
[inaudible]
way, way wait, podcast is not over.
I'm Jad and back from the meeting and Robert Forgot to read the credits.
So here I am to do, to do that for him. Um,
thank you to cal tech for providing us with the audio and for choosing you
Crowley to give the talk. Radio lab is funded by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
the corporation for public broadcasting, the National Science Foundation.
I'm Jack and Ron. Thanks for listening.